[Music]
[Music]
choose me so yeah oh yeah ah well look
who decided to show up
sup cuties Oh weren't even sure we were
still friends it's a long time sorry
I've been busy with stuff stuff right
you know I got a lot of my mind right
graduating all this year hopefully I
don't know why you don't say next year
and just call you like me and Scott like
I always say why rush it through four
years yeah my parents would really
appreciate that you know they'd
appreciate you picking up another major
you know right now I got business
management and art studies you guys are
nuts where are you off to in such a
hurry I don't know but that was probably
good a time as I need to figure it out
right I don't wanna stay here forever
speak for yourself man I cannot leave
parties [ __ ] this is paradise we have
everything we need right here I think I
need different things Scott how do you
think you're better than us dr. Elliott
Chan off to go through the world of
testicular cancer now one ball at a time
I'm just trying to get the hell out of
here before you leave dr. chan
we have tonight's party to attend where
many a lady will need to be treated for
sluttiness is that your formal diagnosis
why don't you take a look at tonight's
guest list I am ruling
I've definitely hooked up with that girl
and in that girl - yeah she could barely
remember own name you slept with her
someone had to Elliot there were many
kids in Africa well we're not letting
any dudes in tonight and no sixes or
below chicks no tickle oh no sir I sure
like eight to eat the one what are you
guys even gonna do with that many girls
it's almost impractical we're gonna do
whatever we want man
[ __ ] alphas I don't even know what
that means anymore of course you do
you know exactly what that means we walk
in there we can [ __ ] anyone we want you
can do anything don't act like you
didn't join this frat three years ago to
do exactly this I'd run for the
friendship [ __ ] you join for the
same reason as us how much [ __ ] would
you get before huh you were a little
[ __ ] we all were
I'm just saying while we're here let's
just have a little fun
amen what happened yeah you changed I
don't know just don't feel right tell
you what it is hanging out one of those
weirdos too much but not where does what
let's just go to the party
put a couple drinks will see this anyone
there who can make you change your mind
huh all right yeah
don't try to copy me but can't knock me
y'all monopoly get pretend Oh in the
back that y'all got a pin flow I just to
make sure that you clear where the
ground all they are overall